It's crazy that we haven't had a live-action
Star Wars show yet, but in 2019, it's finally
happening.
It's been a long time coming, but we have
a little bit of information about the very
first live-action Star Wars series, The Mandalorian,
and we can't wait to share it with you.
A frontier far, far away
They say the Star Wars universe has room for
an infinite number of stories, and now we
know what this particular story is, kind of.
In October 2018, series creator and writer
Jon Favreau made a post on Instagram laying
out the basics.
According to Favreau, the new Star Wars show
will focus on "the travails of a lone gunfighter
in the outer reaches of the galaxy far from
the authority of the New Republic."
The "lone gunfighter" phrase is telling, making
it sound like The Mandalorian will be a space-flavored
take on the western genre, treating outer
space like the lawless expanse that it is.
"Point is, it's just us, out here."
Star Wars already owes a debt to westerns.
The story goes that George Lucas screened
Sergio Leone's Once Upon a Time in the West
for the Star Wars crew before filming, and
that's an easy story to believe.
The original Star Wars trilogy is full of
nods to classic westerns, heck, Star Wars'
sound editors reportedly even gave Boba Fett
the sound of spurs jangling when he walks.
It looks like The Mandalorian will lean into
the genre, too.
Manda-what?
In Star Wars lore, Mandalorians are fierce
warriors with a long, proud, and surprisingly
complex history.
You may not have seen them before, but you're
probably familiar with their most iconic outfits.
Boba Fett wears Mandalorian armor, as did
his father, the bounty hunter Jango Fett.
Despite their fashion sense, they aren't Mandalorians
themselves.
Mandalore has never played a role in the movies,
and you won't ever actually hear the word
"Mandalorian" in the original trilogy.
But the society and its struggles are a big
part of Star Wars' different animated series.
In The Clone Wars, Mandalore is a place ravaged
by centuries of war, with the chaos being
severe enough to provide an opening for none
other than Darth Maul to conquer the planet.
Naturally, he uses it as a headquarters for
his criminal syndicate.
Sabine Wren, one of the main characters on
Star Wars Rebels, is also a Mandalorian, one
who plays an important part in quelling the
society's warring ways.
Edge of the world
During an interview at the premiere of Solo,
Jon Favreau went ahead and explained when
The Mandalorian is supposed to take place,
and the time period sounds full of opportunity.
Favreau explained that The Mandalorian takes
place about seven years after Return of the
Jedi, or roughly two decades before The Force
Awakens.
By this point, the Rebel Alliance has transformed
into the New Republic, while the former Imperials
who'd eventually form the First Order are
still licking their wounds in the galaxy's
Unknown Regions.
The Mandalorian is purported to have a remote
setting, taking place far away from the New
Republic, so we'd be surprised to see any
characters from the movies show up.
When The Mandalorian takes place, Luke would
be busy scouring the galaxy for Force-sensitive
artifacts and old Jedi knowledge.
Poe would still be a little kid, Finn would
be an infant, and Rey wouldn't even have been
born yet.
One big Rebels connection
Jon Favreau isn't adapting Star Wars to the
small screen on his own.
"There is another."
The Iron Man director is also getting a hand
from a creator some fans will recognize: Dave
Filoni.
He may not be a household name, but if you're
a modern day Star Wars fan, you probably know
his work.
Filoni directed The Clone Wars feature film,
which, let's face it, isn't really something
to brag about.
But he also worked side-by-side with George
Lucas to bring the subsequent, superior animated
series to the air.
Filoni also co-created both Rebels and the
newest Star Wars cartoon, Resistance.
In other words, he's the guy behind a lot
of the best of parts modern Star Wars canon.
According to The Art of Star Wars: The Clone
Wars, Filoni is the brains behind Anakin Skywalker's
beloved apprentice, Ahsoka Tano.
On Rebels, Filoni and his staff raised questions
about the Jedi's relationship with the Force
years before The Last Jedi.
He even voiced Chopper, Rebels' scene-stealing
droid.
Now, Filoni will be bringing his take on Star
Wars to The Mandalorian, too.
He's one of the show's executive producers,
and he'll make his live-action directing debut
by helming The Mandalorian's very first episode.
The other big Rebels connection
We're about to get into spoiler territory.
If you haven't seen the series finale of Star
Wars Rebels yet, you may want to duck out
for this part.
While The Mandalorian has a title, a premise,
and a setting in time, it still doesn't have
a cast, at least, not one that's been announced.
But we do have some ideas.
Shortly after the series was announced, a
theory emerged that the mysterious lead character
of The Mandalorian is none other than the
demolitions expert and Star Wars Rebels star
Sabine Wren.
The series ends with Sabine and Ahsoka on
a quest to find the villains Thrawn and Ezra
after the fall of the Empire, the sort of
mission that could conceivably take somebody
to the very edge of known space.
Sabine's got the right ancestry, too, and
it does seem curious that we haven't seen
our hero's face yet.
Throw in Filoni's involvement and the fact
that, hey, that really could be a woman in
there, and you've got a decent argument that
Sabine is the Mandalorian of the series title.
Maybe it's a long shot, but what's in store
will be exciting to watch unfold either way.
We'll find out more when the series touches
down in 2019.